en plein coeur de la crise sanitaire et
à quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle le maire de poissy sort
un nouveau livre intitulé ce beau pays
qui est le mien karl olive propose des
pistes de solution pour redonner aux
français qu'ils ont perdu le goût de
leur pays moi je pense que ici en france
on est à un pays comme le disait sylvain
tesson un paradis peuplé de gens qui se
croient en enfer et je veux montrer aux
français qu' il ya tellement de choses
qui nous rassemblent à côté de tout ce
qui peut nous diviser le maire des
pisciacais étaient présents le 21
décembre dans la librairie du pain frais
pour dédicacer son livre en
avant-première moi je suis ravi d'être
ici puis je suis à l'enfant de poissy
donc ça fait plaisir de devoir les
pisciacais et l'épicier qui parfois bon
vu grandir et ils étaient nombreux au
rendez vous pour pouvoir rencontrer le
maire l'idée c'est de rencontrer
monsieur olives en fait que j'apprécie
bien fort son pragmatisme en fait au
quotidien non dans les sujets qu'ils
traitent dans sa ville en fait ça
m'intéresse de voir les solutions qu'il
a apporté et m'a répondu municipal et
peut-être nationale c'est beau pays qui
est le mien paraîtra le 6 janvier